-Guys,
it can be hard to say goodbye,
but sometimes you have to
and there are a few things
I'd like to say goodbye to
right now.
It's time for
"Go On, Git."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, go on, go on, git ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go on, git, commercials that
list all the medications',
potential side effects.
I know you're tryin' to look out
for me but I don't wanna hear
about something called
elbow rash
when I'm watchin'
"Below Deck."
I got some side effects for you,
mild going
and severe go on, gittin'.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Spits ]
[ Spittoon clangs ]
-Go on, git, pointy paper cups!
Who looks at a cup and said
"I wish this was sharper
and impossible to sit down?"
Nobody.
Here's some water cooler talk
for yah -- go on, git!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Spits ]
[ Spittoon clangs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go on, git, Oscar statue.
Why does an award for mastery in
film making have to look like
someone just dipped Jeff Bezos
in Velveeta?
[ Laughter ]
Oscar statue, congratulations,
you just won yourself the award
for best go on, git.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go on, git, detectives on TV
covering their entire
bedroom wall with evidence.
Don't you have an office?!
[ Laughter ]
Also, no one has ever
solved a damn murder
by connecting
photos with yarn!
[ Laughter ]
Now, stick a push pin in your
hat and git!
-Git!
-[ Spits ]
[ Spittoon clangs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go on, git, teeny tiny
fashion glasses.
You look adorable on cats but
make the rest of us look like
we're extras in "The Matrix."
You're revived, no one's saying
you ain't,
but it's time to see the big
picture and git.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Go on, git, people who heart
every interaction
in a text thread.
It's nice to know you read my
message but let's be real,
you didn't love that I wrote,
"Be there in 10."
[ Laughter ]
have you not been acquainted
with the thumbs-up reaction?
If I had to pick
a reaction for you,
it'd be in big bubble letters
that say, "Git!"
[ Laughter ]
-Go on, git, the word antiquing.
We don't need a separate --
[ Laughter ]
I felt a breeze come through.
-Yes, it's a little, little,
little windy in here.
-It went that way.
-Yeah.
Oh, I think a breeze is coming
back the other way I think.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Go on, git, tumbleweed.
-Well, go on, git, tumbleweed.
Git outta here.
-Git outta here!
[ Spits ]
-Whoo!
[ Spittoon clangs ]
-[ Spits ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Spittoon clangs ]
-[ Spits ]
Go on, git, the word antiquing.
You don't need a separate word
for going to the antique store.
It's be like if we call going to
the grocery store "fooding."
[ Laughter ]
We're going to the IKEA,
kla-vark-en-ing.
[ Laughter ]
It's a fun hobby for yah.
Here's one, it's called
"go on, gitten."
[ Applause ]
-Go on, git, combination
shampoo body wash.
Sure, you sound impressive,
but we all know that face skin
is different than leg skin,
right.
Now, go squirt your Pert
somewhere else, now just git!
-Ah, now git and it's hard to
see 'em go.
But I'm glad I got to see it out
of my system.
My thanks to Ethan Hawke,
we'll be talking with him
after the break,
no go on, git.
[ Cheers and applause ]